hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the room your
creepy why are you staring at me like
that okay
once again diving in no prior knowledge
oh I like the rain
the rain can clear everything wash off
the dirty things from me dirty things
like sand mud blood or sin I like the
rain okay this guy likes rain I wonder
if this guy sorry my name age or other
personal data's are not important the
only important thing that's better if
you know about me is my early life okay
alright fine by me I am NOT proud to
myself because the result of my earlier
actions is a sanatorium your grammar is
a little off too
I'm here since five years five long
years and make stupid medical tests and
tasks day by day but now I'm clean ah I
don't remember too my past but the
doctors don't allow me why not
I'm not L I want out okay so apparently
this guy is cuckoo crazy apparently that
guy staying there am I done oh yeah okay
well welcome to you what can you see on
this picture got a face going on there
sad first it's um a crown I think I will
be a king I'm already king of the
squirrel don't need you it's a puppy
it's a puppy
thank you it's cute right
okay whoa hello perspective is a little
wonky things are oh hello creepy little
kid picture from a little girl I don't
remember who she is okay um they're the
thingies clang clang okay so we got a
bunch of stuff in the room the little
low res but I never hold that against a
game
I hear rain and the lights kind of
flickering those dirty can't see
anything there's a big picture Gaga
clothes
no kit please release me like the rain
please I didn't catch with that last bit
setting it's closed yeah the door is
closed thank you very much
um I don't see anything else boxes whoa
okay huh
apparently I jumped straight up without
moving forward at all oh that's okay
haha alright then
okay why did the rain stop why did the
rain stop what's going on what's going
on is there something weird about the
snow seems ha ha ha ha ha oh you [ __ ]
what the hell
the pictures look different save like
that face to me sad face what the hell
just happened we'll kid you gotta go dee
Banach on me over the window what about
the window hey over there no thank you
oh god please little y ou may be better
if I go to sleep no I do not think OHS
can I get out of here please
what come on it's jammed I can't open it
ok
good night good night
why would I want to cut asleep my first
victim Optus whoa what ah where are you
oh how are you son of a [ __ ]
show yourself threatening blood is there
someone else in this room with me there
can I go to sleep again not owning
asleep again
that's it locked what am i doing ha ha
ha oh come on
Oh she wet I'll be Bonnie Tommy it must
be a dream a bad dream oh my god
Oh No huh
it's so big I think I see eyeballs where
am i I'm are you oh yeah
that's close
what the hell is going on here Oh No
what are you what are you oh you uh well
I said I think I see something something
there something was there something
something something something something
something was here in some wet smelled
opening damn it why can't you open it it
like a screwdriver there's got to be
like a screwdriver some here I don't
know I can hardly see anything with that
light flickering like that
and there's some ghostly lady in here
with me gotta be something else here to
dirty Kantian Zeke salvation salvation
not for me salvation duffer may forget
here I must seem crazy if they're
observing me and I'm like jumping over
the walls and like grabbing my hands all
over everything
I wish I would stop jumping so weird
hey I'm just going to look for something
I'm clicking on everything locked you're
locked
oh holy bahaha it's a bad dream a bad
dream
too bad Dean Britt Pat Dean Britt bad
dream Bri yeah I don't know why the
boxes are there either crates or
whatever you want to call them odd
wooden crates if it's wet smell or
smells
maybe one will work yes I made it
what I mean to what
I can't go further here lies a rat but
eat them no no and Oh what wait what oh
hi the rats kami but bull Steph I owe
the option
shut up shut up I'm going back to sleep
ah Tess I gotta eat the rats donut what
the hell this is so weird
ah all right yeah see threads oh that
was just another game crashing what our
god what the what the body hell why did
it crash I don't get it I don't get it
welcome sad face
a crown I'll be king someday a puppy
damn it ah [ __ ] hell and back in the
beginning [ __ ] what happens will let me
out what the hell happened what the hell
happened let me out
okay I don't know what happened but I
think I'm done for now cuz holy crap oh
I'm done I'm done if I get my game
crashed something screwed up but I don't
care at this point because I'm done so
let's uh let's just let's calm down for
a second here everybody calm down
everybody down take a deep breath okay
alright so I'm all done here so let me
know the links in the description below
play for yourself maybe there's
something I missed you guys can tell me
but um just play for yourself it was
good I liked it but I'm out of here
so thank you all so much for watching
clicking annotation for more videos if
i've done and as always I will see you
in the
by
Oh
your turn
Lord